now
this is
a one-step equation okay there's only
one thing i need to do to it in order to
get y on its own that's what we're
trying to do right solve uh the equation
which means get whatever whatever letter
whatever prone rule get it by itself
okay
so being that this is why i divided by
four
what i should do you might have seen as
i was talking to you to go around
helping you the way to get onsite is to
do the opposite of dividing by four
which is
multiply by four good so i'm gonna have
this
you multiply one side by four you better
multiply the other side
uh it's the same heading as yesterday
you could make it one step equations if
you like but no don't do that because
there will be
more stepping stones
two y two one
okay now what we're going to get on the
left hand tied the divide by four and
then multiply by four they're going to
cancel leaving us with y now at this
point you've got a couple of choices you
do have a calculator there so you can
punch in five and three eighths and and
do it okay now here's the thing though i
am going to caution against you doing
that in a minute i'll let you do it so
we make sure we get the right answer the
reason why it's a little dangerous to
try and start relying on a calculator is
because
um you do have some letters
on your calculator okay you've got well
at least not mine i've got an a b c d an
x y and an m okay you can use them to
put values in
but on our calculators you can't use
them to solve equations i can't put y in
there and ask the calculator to tell me
okay what's it equal to can't solve
equations in fact you know how they talk
about uh in the hsc or in your formal
assessment they talk about
board approved calculators
and they're talking about the board of
studies right so there's a big list of
calculators that are approved like the
ones that you guys have
the categories that aren't approved one
of the things that they can do is they
can solve equations like there's a solve
button on there when i go around i have
to check for exams or naplan that kind
of thing one of the things i'm looking
for is that's one of the things that our
calculators aren't supposed to do
because it's a skill that we want you to
develop that's kind of the point okay
so being that you can't put letters in
it's dangerous to start relying on a
calculator in general when you're trying
to solve equations okay
so what would i do if i didn't have a
calculator what could we do this how do
you multiply 5 and 3 8 by four
okay i can treat it the way i treat
normal fractions right um if i had for
instance if i had a half times seven
right i would take the numbers on the
top really that's a seven over one isn't
it right i multiply one by seven which
gives me seven and then i'll go two by
one which is two no problems three and a
half okay
say that again
okay now then the question would be is
there some cancelling and the answer is
yes there is but it's difficult
if it's not a proper fraction or an
improper fraction what is this thing
what's it called
it's more than just a fraction it's a
fixed fraction it's a mixed numeral
right
you've got a you've got a whole number
and a fraction together right that's the
next thing i was going to say so what i
need to do is
change this guy into an improper
fraction then i can work with it right
how do i do that how do i change five
and three eighths
you gave me the answer but the question
is how i want to know how you do it tom
i was stretching that's fine so i want
to have a go amy yeah like
five by eight or something okay the five
and the eight are going to have to
interact me write this is a big guy
but it's it's not division it's
multiplication okay so here let me write
it like this i like to think of it kind
of like a circle okay i'll get you a
second early
it is five times eight five times eight
okay what is five times eight
it's 40. what you do is you add that so
five times eight
right you get 40 and what you do is you
add that to the top
that's how you get 43 over eight okay in
case you're like wait what like why is
that i'll show you why um it's a mixed
number right we said it's a whole number
and a fraction
but really it's code four like we're
just being lazy it's five plus three
over eight right it's actually two
numbers yeah
but i can get this guy i can put him on
a common denominator and i can work him
out
if i want these two to mix together i
need them as
eighths right i need them both to be
eight so the question is how many eights
are there in five
and the answer is there are
forty-eighths
right these two numbers are equivalent
are they 40 divided by eight is five is
that all right
do you see how i did that
so if that's 40 that's where i get that
plus 40 from right
that's the five and there's the three
over eight hanging off on the side right
so that's 43 over a so if if this part
here it's kind of like oh that's a bit
mysterious bit of a black box why do you
do that
this is why and i recommend if this is a
bit shady you should write this down
question
um i'm just revealing that yep question
yep when you do that
five over or five things
three over eight and then that answer
like 43 do you times that by four yes
exactly right so what i've done is i've
worked out what just what that part is
that part alone i've sorted him out
right you don't usually have to write
off on the side you can't do it here but
i did it just so that it's clear what
i'm working on okay so i am going to
write that 43 over eight
times
now we will get our calculator data set
to confirm this but
like you will often have to interact
with these numbers when there's printers
involved right in which case your
calculator is going to let you down
that's why i'm trying to emphasize to
you even though you're like this is
fractions this is year seven right but
you need to have these skills in place
so you don't get confused
all right
now i think was it chloe or amy who said
we can do some cancelling here
yeah good we can do some canceling here
can't we what can i cancel
the four and the eight what should i
divide both of them by
four i could do two but a better number
is four because that's two and then two
again okay so i'm gonna do both of those
if i divide this by four i just get one
if you divide eight by four you get
i suppose we could tie it up a little
bit like it started off with mixed
numerals so it's kind of nice to give it
back as mixed new rules and that looks
like it'll be 21 and a half 21.5 okay so
as we said before just in case you
couldn't remember you do have a mixed
numeral button this is why you should
have your calculators at you should know
how to use it right the mixed neuro
button is just above the if you go shift
and then fraction you get the mixed
numeral and you can put the um
you know the button looks like this
something like that or i think one of
them is shaded right so if you press uh
let's see shift fraction and then you
can put all of your numbers in place
using your
cursor keys and then you just multiply
by four and sure enough at least my
calculator it goes to this point and you
can
press the sd button to get a decimal if
you want not that you would
because they didn't give you the
question decimal but it would be the
same answer okay
so i guess the point is
you can use a calculator at this point
that's the point at which we can right
but you still need to know how to do it
without just in case the kind of
question they give you you can't do